- I'm going to have the
cheesy bacon burger.
But no cheese and no bacon.
And could I get it lettuce-wrapped?
Add Gorgonzola cheese.
- Okay, no problem.
(bleep)
- Sorry, can I send this back?
I didn't like it that much.
- Sure.
- Thanks.
(bleep)
- Hi, you guys ready to put in your order?
- Oh, I haven't even
looked yet, I'm sorry.
- Okay, I'll be back in five minutes.
(bleep)
- Alright, you ladies ready
to put in your order now?
- Oh, you know I was
caught up in talking and...
- I'll be back.
- Aww (beep)
- How about now?
- Still haven't looked.
Can I just get a water?
- Just a water?
Okay. (bleep)
(bleep)
(girls talking in background)
- So, how would you like to pay?
(bleep)
- Hey, you guys are still open right?
- Yeah, sure.
(bleep)
- Are you (bleep) kidding me?
(lively music)
(bleep)